the veterans coming home from war is is
one of the most important issues of our
time you see these people and I became
very attached to all of the characters
in the movie and really started to feel
for what they're going through and what
they feel as they come home for more and
so for me to work on this film and to
make this film it filled in so much I
mean I've experienced some things in my
life with tragedy and in the mountains
and of course the veterans saw that on a
scale that I can't even comprehend
losing friends and losing parts of their
bodies and so much so that it's one of
those projects that you dream about for
an entire career and hope for a chance
to work on on something like this well
there are organizations that are working
with veterans who come home from war and
in this case it was an organization that
was world team sports and no barriers
are two organizations that no barriers
is Eric wine mayor the blind climbers
organization and this this expedition
came out of a 10 year anniversary of
Eric wine mayor's Everest climb and as a
team we were looking for something
meaningful to do because the mountains
had given us so much and that climb with
Erica had really defined our careers and
helped us along and so 10 years later it
felt like we should do something
meaningful and try to give back somehow
that veterans tend to be fairly close
they don't want to talk about what
happened and as as we went along we got
to know them a little bit and we've
gained some trust and they heard our
stories as we heard their stories and
they heard about climbing Everest and
avalanches and the things that happen
and then we heard about getting blown up
and losing friends and so as time went
by we developed that trust and of course
the mountain itself was a very difficult
climb and so that it was like a mission
in combat maybe
you had some goal to accomplish and
really had to work for it and so in that
process we got to know them better and
then after the film after we climbed the
mountain that's when not the magical
thing that happens only rarely in a
filmmakers career maybe as you get a
mentor who's just top-notch and in this
case it was Don Hahn and he he did I
showed him the trailer because we've
been acquainted through a film festival
and he asked if he could become involved
and that was music to my ears because we
didn't have the resources to really or
the creativity and amazing things like
Chris Bacon's music and Gary risotto to
do the sound mix and at Skywalker and
the things that as a filmmaker from
Colorado honestly it's it's a dream a
mountain has is a beautiful metaphor for
story because you have an approach and
then you have a steep part in the middle
where you might get an action piece and
then you have the summit which is
another subtly different action piece
but when and sometimes as a documentary
film like here you really just like it
was the night before we were about to go
up and we're really thinking about like
putting our boots on and and really
because you know all of us that are that
are climbing there were two of us
shooting we had to really be thinking
about okay we're gonna climb this
mountain also and then Rizzo the woman
who decided not to go on the climb calls
us all into the tent and so it's it's
sort of one of those balancing acts to
you what do we do okay I've got to get
ready but this is going to be important
because she's probably gonna say she's
not going to go and I kind of had a
sense of that because she'd been sick
the night before and so that was one of
those moments and even when Steve
struggles on the climb you see him just
really really struggle and you can feel
that and that visceral kind of feeling
that comes with it and so and then
building back in time just different
moments that happened along the way
where Steve broke down and just talks
about staring into a black abyss and
those moments that just
each time one of those happens it's like
okay this is something that really
matters because it's demonstrating what
I really wanted to accomplish with this
but when you do a mountain climb we
didn't know going into that day in that
night what was going to happen and
whether or not any of us would make it
to the top so it keeps it kind of
exciting right to the end